Alien: Covenant promised to explore the mysterious
and goopy lineage of the xenomorph species
that we all know and love.
But in many cases, it just left the entire
Alien franchise open to even more questions.
Let's burrow into Covenant, stick our ovipositors
down its throat, and see how many answers
are still waiting to hatch.
And, of course, spoilers are hatching beyond
this point.
So cover your face, okay?
Who are the Engineers?
More than anything else, Covenant needed to
explain just what the heck its prequel Prometheus
was all about.
Prometheus introduced us to the Engineers,
an alien race who inexplicably started life
on Earth.
We don't know exactly why, and that's what
the crew of the Prometheus sets out to discover.
"What we hope to achieve, was to meet our
makers—to get answers.
Why they even made us in the first place."
However, once the android David actually finds
the Engineers and all of the answers are within
reach… he slimes them.
An entire city of Engineers is destroyed by
David's stock of evil black goo.
We never learn who the Engineers are, why
they do what they do, or where they came from.
And thanks to David, we may never know.
Why did David kill the Engineers?
The motivations of the Covenant's human crew
are pretty straightforward: just don't die.
However, the Alien franchise's androids tend
to be a little harder to read, and none are
more confusing than David.
It becomes clear in both Prometheus and the
introduction to Covenant that David sees himself
as superior to humans, and even expresses
the bizarre idea that all creations want to
kill their creators.
"Kill all humans, must kill all humans."
Sure, you might be mad at mom for not letting
you borrow the car on a school night, but
that's pretty much the extent of matricidal
rage that most people reach.
So why exactly does David wipe out the Engineers?
It's possible that, as mankind's implied creators,
David is just taking his murder plot one step
deeper into his ancestry, but there isn't
a whole lot of meaning there.
And he definitely doesn't do it to protect
Earth from the Engineers.
So what's the deal?
What did the goo do?
When we meet David again in Covenant, he leads
the crew into the derelict city of the Engineers,
through masses of their dead bodies.
Of course, they're all dead thanks to David's
goo.
But what exactly did this goo do?
As far as anyone can tell, it mutates any
living animal it comes into contact with,
but we never find out what it did to the Engineers.
If the goo did what goo usually does, the
entire Engineer planet would be swarming with
xenomorphs.
So where did all of those potential xenomorphs
end up after ten years?
What happened in the five minutes after the
goo drop?
Why was the Engineers' planet lifeless?
The planet that the Covenant lands on is ideal
for life, but inexplicably, the crew can't
seem to find any.
No birds, no bugs, just silence.
As David tells his guests, the virus he dispersed
was made to seek out hosts, so all of the
meat on the planet became an immediate target
as soon as he dropped his payload.
But none of the 'morphs that would have resulted
from his attack seem to still be around.
Nothing is.
Ultimately, trying to comprehend what goo
can and cannot do is a job best left for Ridley
Scott's pulsating nightmares.
But that mysterious decade where David was
left to his own messed-up devices leaves too
many mysteries for the continuity-concerned.
For now, let's just say it was Predators.
What's up with those spores?
The crew of the Covenant gets their first
taste of alien madness when a couple of dinguses
brush against some plants, suck in some alien
dust, and after a little while, have monsters
bursting out of their giblets.
It's basic science.
Except human DNA and Engineer DNA are, allegedly,
nearly identical.
It wouldn't make much biological sense if
the Engineers' planet was rife with a virulent
strain of murder-monster mushrooms.
So these balls of alien death-confetti must
not have always been there.
Instead, they must have been caused by David's
use of the goo.
The goo can mutate every animal it comes in
contact with — so why did it very selectively
choose one plant to turn into a vehicle for
the species?
Arguably, it's not a plant at all that shoots
out those spores, but that still leaves questions.
Were these pods part of David's later experiments?
And if so, why are Facehuggers treated as
a superior form of alien evolution?
The spores' method of propagating the species
is only a million times more efficient than
the alien egg pods.
The choice is simple: your species propagates
because an idiot actively agitates a giant,
ugly egg and waits for its terrifying contents
to attack and shove an egg tube down their
throat...or your species lives on because
something gently brushes against a small pod
with their toe.
The more efficient method is clear.
So what makes the eggs more evolutionarily
sound than the spores?
Is David the xenomorph whisperer?
It's easy to argue that aliens aren't overly
interested in androids because they don't
really have a lot of delicious edible parts.
So if you're a synthetic being, you pretty
much get a xenomorph hall pass.
But why are the xenomorphs David is cultivating
strangely loyal to him?
At the very least, they seem to see him as
one of the only living things that's not worth
immediately killing — which is really saying
something when you're an animal designed only
for killing.
We know xenomorphs don't imprint on the first
thing they see like many Earth animals, so
how does David automatically have this dominion
over the beasts?
Maybe we'll learn the answer in a sequel.
And while we're on the subject of synthetics...
Is Walter still alive?
Alien is a franchise that relishes showing
the audience every gory detail of nearly every
bloody death.
So when someone dies and you don't at least
see their viscera-strewn corpse, you know
something might be up.
During the first phase of the big fight between
David and Walter, we see that Walter has the
ability to heal himself.
While he takes a few minutes to reboot, it
seems like he can recover from some pretty
deep cuts.
"Now stand aside, worthy adversary!"
"'tis but a scratch!"
"A scratch?
Your arm's off!"
"No, it isn't."
After the second phase of their big battle,
we learn that David comes out on top and switches
places with Walter.
We never learn Walter's fate.
But when even an earlier android model like
David can survive decapitation, we can assume
that Walter is still alive.
Or can we?
Everyone knows that you can't keep a good
'droid down.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!